the way you judge to me
who is the real candidate is who the
opposing side trashes more okay so so
check this out here check this out this
kind of validates his point okay go to
page six go to page six
uh january 6
panel member floats 14th amendment as a
way
to bar trump from holding office this is
a washington examiner story
neither of donald trump's impeachment
trials led to his conviction which would
have prevented him from returning to the
white house
representative jamie raskin said has
another idea on how to borrow the former
president raskin suggested that the
constitutional provision preventing
those who engage in insurrection as or
rebellion from holding office may
prevent trump from becoming the
president for a second non-consecutive
term having lost to president joe biden
2020 trump is eligible for another white
house term polls show him the clear
favor to win the 2024 republican
nomination if he runs if there are
people who did participate in
insurrectional rebellion they're
constitutionally barred from holding
federal or state office again we're
asking a member of the white house
select committee reform the
investigation general
there's also another part of you know
for example donald trump has already
been determined to have participated in
the insurrection rebellion by the
virtual picture okay so you see where
the story goes yeah that's bad news for
george washington and john adams huh
yeah the the place where i'm going with
this is where i'm going with this is
who is mainstream media trashing the
most today
that's who you gotta look at as the
number one yeah so so so i think they're
still this is the one guy
i was watching don lemon and chris cuomo
the night uh biden one when it was
announced at biden one and you see don
lemon's like
look i don't care what you're just
you're with us because we won and this
is you know this is just very emotional
right now
good don lemon right now did you see don
how he trashed biden last night i did no
i don't hate myself enough to watch this
yeah anymore yeah i was pretty bad i
mean well binds have a horrible week
with the voting rights and the and the
mask mandates
uh
come on man worst week of a presidency
could possibly have it's been a terrible
week for that guy to the point where don
comes after you
and mainstream media comes after you so
charlemagne the god yeah this website
called babylon b fake news you can trust
claims
kamala harris is so bad hillary clinton
dangerous website yes i don't know if
you know that side or not so
point is who the hell is
going to run on the other side we still
can't come up with a name on that side
i don't know michelle obama discussed
that last time we'll see anyways okay so
that's the part with trump's story let
me go to another hillary clinton's
considering losing again is there i mean
is there no shame with this january 6
stuff i mean is there just no shame
whatsoever they're just they found their
narrative they're sticking to it and and
this almost goes to what you were saying
before pat like you could fool people
some of the time and not all the time
there's so many democrats that i know i
mean i grew up with nothing but
democrats and as soon as they compared
this to 9 11 everybody around us was
like
uh
what coming in what's up now what i'm
saying to you what's loyalty loyalty is
loyalty is you know you have to know
that there's your parents you ever seen
your parents are like okay yeah i don't
know mom yeah
no that doesn't make any sense yeah that
i don't i don't know if we're going that
far
no matter when a bad argument is
presented you're going to sit there and
you're going to say
listen i know i'm a democrat yeah i'm a
registered democrat my entire life i
voted democrat i disagree with you it's
let's say 9 11. this is a completely
different story they've lost their mind
when they go to a different angle so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]